hello on a very warm welcome to this
latest edition of talking Germany the
show where we do just that my guest
today is a computer scientist who is
viewed as one of the leading experts on
developments in the IT sector here in
Germany she's also an uncomfortable and
insistent warning voice on issues such
as data protection government
surveillance programs and data retention
and here she is in person Constanza
courts thank you very much for joining
us here today on talking German thank
you for having me great to have you here
now concern sir Corts has been described
as a leading civil rights activist but
at the same time she says that her
biggest hobby is computer hacking how
some might ask does that fit together
well we will also be talking about the
world of work and how its organized and
what the future has to hold there that
is another area where Constanza has a
lot to tell us but Khan Center I first
of all want to go back to that question
you are a civil rights activist on the
one hand and a computer hacker on the
other for you that's probably the most
normal thing in the world yeah for some
people like myself it doesn't quite fit
together or at least I ask myself how
does it fit together well actually there
are a lot of digital human rights and
that's why I'm fighting for actually the
word has dominated of course from your
technology we use it every day we are in
a way dependent on that and so somebody
has to fight and be an activist for
those digital human rights mmm but that
means as a hacker a hacker is a person
who breaks into things not really oh the
term it's a bit more ambivalent I guess
of course hacking is breaking in a
bulova pressing the aeropress but the
drummond hacker community considers
themselves as the white hat hackers we
have Hagar e-cigs and with we try to
separate from the criminals yeah but let
me my really need to understand this you
have the capacities from the comfort of
your own home before you come on this
show talking Germany with Peter Craven
to find out more about Peter Craven than
I would possibly like you to know well
that it's possible
it's got nothing to do with hacking no
that's more using information system in
a professional way it's not hacking
really but in the the sense of hacking
as breaking I have some capabilities but
I'm not a yeah well and online banking
hecker or something and I never did that
you're one of the good guys this is what
you're trying to talk about good guys
and bad guys later you are one over you
your computer scientist you viewed as an
IT expert a very prominent IT expert
here in Germany when was your first
encounter with a computer this was in
the eastern part of germany when I was
well I don't know 12 maybe 12 years old
in East Germany you had a computer but
you had access to it didn't he look like
a computer as we know it now because
well it didn't have really a large
displayed was quite small and we were
trying to learn basic which is a
programming language oh yeah and was it
love at first sight I know ah no not
really be you know we had a computer for
I don't know three or four of the pupils
and you know even gets a chance to try
anything it was more like a lesson it
was not love at the first set okay okay
yeah well Constanza course we haven't
mentioned this yet so far but it's
coming up is she's the spokeswoman of
what is called the Chaos Computer Club
which is Europe's largest hacker group I
was fascinated to discover that this
influential organization has a history
that goes back three decades let's find
out what it gets up to
fascinating stuff some very old footage
there from 30 years ago and you
recognize some of the people sure yeah
and other people you recognize that they
still hackus is it I mean people say
once a Catholic always a Catholic is it
once a hacker always a hacker I guess so
for for the most of the members but they
are just few in the beginning 3,000
people but we have three generations of
hackers right now and some our
grandfathers already fascinating stuff
eh what are they what the Chaos Computer
Club what are the goals of the club are
they formulated yeah they are formulated
of course that it's very German we
formulate our gold and but it's not it's
a community that that actually came into
place because people search for other
presents who use computers three decades
ago that went well a normal thing to do
and so the founding members a search for
other technology and computer people so
it's a cure it's a computer
communication club in a lot of great it
was about sharing knowledge sharing
ideas sharing hardware and of course it
had a political agenda from that's the
political agenda then the political
agenda is about freedom of information
yeah about the right to heck hmm that's
of course about data privacy but also
the machine-readable government so we
have a lot of political goals too ok
we're going to talk about privacy in
just a second what were what are the why
is it called the Chaos Computer Club why
not the neat and tidy Computer Club well
the chaos is not only in the name it was
well of the chaos just for hecka a
positive term it's a way of life right
in a way huh hmm what are what are the
rules what can you not do we have the
written heco esox which are which is a
kind of normative ethic ok but it's also
about talking with each other if you
come to great gray areas um and it's the
knowledge transfer between although
hackers and
younger people trying learning to use
computers that's quite important and on
larger events which we have we also have
a hotline the ethics hotline where you
can call and ask questions before you
press enter okay on all these issues
about freedom and about the about the
digital world the Chaos Computer Club is
viewed as extremely influential here in
Germany it's viewed as pretty
influential in the in the media outside
Germany as well it's often quoted often
used as a source what does that tell us
about Germany does that tell us that
Germany is is somewhere at the forefront
of these kind of debates about her about
freedoms in the net I guess we had a lot
of public debate large years long
debates about technology about
regulation of technology use of
technology and especially about data
privacy data retention that was really
our large discussion on high a political
spheres and the Chaos Computer Club is
mostly known for of course its technical
expertise if you want to ask somebody to
understand like government malware or
possibilities that come with data
retention then the heck eyes are the
persons you can ask and we give answers
hmmm it's mostly about explaining
técnicas well that's interesting the
role of the role of giving ounces of
explaining as you put it you were
actually invited to be a member of a
government Commission on IT and the net
and what have you what what was what was
your contribution what did you say italy
in the german parliament they had that
commission mm-hmm and i tried really to
figure out the different protocol and
technological topics which future
governments have to regulate and it was
more like a discussion not only about
technology because it was more about
like how we want to deal with those
technology which is in everyday life and
working life and it was really important
that the Parliament did that do you
accept that the Parliament that the
state is that it is part of the job of
the state
to regulate this sector yes or no yes
surely did you accept that yeah but what
you were saying about the kid the Chaos
Computer Club sort of ideals and sort of
manifesto made it sound to me as though
you guys want to regulate yourselves oh
yeah but do you have to make a
difference between information freedom
which we want in any possible way and
the machine-readable government um and
the Internet as a commercial place where
you need regulation because it's where
all about money and all about using the
data and misusing the data and they need
regulation it's about using and abusing
people right in the in the widest sense
yeah yeah how much pressure I mean
you're telling me that you that you you
were allowed to speak to the government
your ads put your point of view forward
your expertise forward at the same time
I can imagine that you're viewed I mean
you've actually you've taken the German
government or you filed a criminal
complaint right I'm being very careful
about my about what I'm saying here
against the German government for aiding
and abetting illegal and prohibited
covert intelligence activities yeah you
were part of that the CCC was part of
that it's unlock that met you that makes
you as far as the government is
concerned a troublemaker have you been
put under pressure as a result of being
a troublemaker no maybe some members of
the government see me as troublemaker
but oh I'm sure the British government
does as well because there's been a
similar case brought partly under your
initiative against the British
government as well but that's on a
higher court that's the human as a
European human rights court because the
Britons of course they they ratified and
the human rights conventions yeah and
that is a different case sometimes they
regret doing yeah well yes sometime true
the go try if laws and those contracts
will help us against those secret
services and I'm maybe some see me as a
troublemaker but I had a lot of support
overwhelmingly support from all over
Europe eze and we had to press statement
about the case that was really
interesting that most of the people
supported us if they even want to send
me my and staff to help and I don't
needed there for but there was a lot of
support room nipple good nice entrusting
interesting insights okay we've always
talked already about computer hacking
and computer hackers and we still
haven't really answered the question are
hackers good guys or bad guys
we could talk about the club matter but
i would like to curb glamour yeah what
do you make of that mr. glamour in the
hacking scene yeah well I don't see that
much glamour but maybe some acres I
don't know we have to make a star
cycling really yeah yeah yeah and they
are well known exactly i mean talking
about stars to use that word we don't
need to you know think about glamour too
much 20 years ago now Steven Levy wrote
a book called the title exactly hackers
heroes of the of the computer revolution
ah hackers still heroes maybe and well
in some sense what Steven diva does was
actually a portray of the formal hacker
community and the hecka mindset it
doesn't change that much it's all about
well sharing your knowledge uh hacking
together but a break for you guys I mean
you say sharing your knowledge I just I
didn't maybe I'm just too narrow-minded
I almost certainly I because I just
don't I just don't get it yeah why would
you share all your knowledge when the
sexy thing about being a hacker is that
you you have access to new knowledge
that other people don't have that's what
makes you the special hacker so why
should you share it with the other guys
well you don't want to invent everything
again you want to reuse knowledge and
experiences some all the heck is made
and that is really part of so hecka
spirit to share that that's important
because you don't have to do it over and
over again what somebody already does
what's wrong with having ideals you know
who said that well I don't know exactly
you did in an interview I was gonna ask
you a question about it but you're
talking about ideals all the time then I
stick on the ideals you were going to
mention black hats and white hats yeah
what's that all about wheat which with
separate from criminals and actually
criminal hackers don't use the term
black hats it's more like a meteor charm
but you have to have terms because
hecker means both means like being an
ethical hacker and being a black hat and
steal someone's
and so exactly because you're talking
here about the idealism of hacking the
whole while a burn I'm thinking but
these guys are trying to break into my
bank you know account and we'll have a
get you yeah we will never get over that
negative connotation and my mom keeps
telling me that it's always good when
people start telling about their mommy
say yeah but in German popular your mum
your mum your mum well she what does to
change the name kales in the chaos
computer club and maybe not being a
hacker anymore because she knows a
negative connotation off the term ok uh
hacktivists are you one of those uh sure
sure I am getting stuff for political
reasons huh ok we've talked a lot about
the data protection always mentioned
data protection we talked a little bit
about privacy you know as well as I do
there are an awful lot of people less so
in Germany has to be said a lot a lot of
people say why is privacy so important
and they don't even care yeah and maybe
it's maybe it's a majority I don't know
of the people but if you talk about
privacy you have not talked about the
Bonjour to you though but for
individuals and it's even a basic human
right and you don't have to defend
yourself if you fight for that privacy
because it's a basic human right and mmm
I guess in Germany is a discussion is a
little bit different from other states
it's a more intensive and it's a large
public debate and even when Chancellor
markets a mobile phone was tapped and
the discussion not really changed
because we have that for I don't know
five or six years we really have a
public immediately bed on sat pages and
that is different from from other
countries but I said but you stole a I
mean I I understand what you're saying
but you still haven't explained to me
sort of philosophically what is so
important about privacy I guess it's a
basic seen every human being needs a
part of the secrets maybe of the medical
condition that you have
or I don't know the money you own that
is private and I guess it's what makes a
human a human in a way you know that a
lot of people in Silicon Valley sort of
the Messianic community in Silicon
Valley they all say privacy is you know
it's what it's a sign that you have
something to hide you sure and but let's
be honest it's all about money i mean
the Silicon Valley companies just want
to make their business case they don't
care about privacy it's more like an
ideology to tell people the privacy
yours over but I don't believe that
because I think we will find back to a
mall again in equilibrium it's also a
wild data West will end I guess I am but
you again when you talk about idealism
and you're talking about like your CCC
people and then you say but and we are
different from these you know the
criminal hackers okay that's two classes
of people two different classes of
people there's also you know every time
I pick up my newspaper it's telling me
that the next global conflict is going
to be some kind of a cyber war and the
hackers are going to be the elite troops
as it were the elite forces so they're
two for me in my little world hackers or
a problem because are a problem in that
case we learned from the Snowden Fayed's
that there really a lot of thousands of
hackers paid by Secret Service to do
that type of war operations to bringing
malware to computers all over the world
I mean we have a problem with hackers
unethical hackers but it's nothing that
I would deny but we want to separate
from that we want to say you can use
your hacking skills for good and ethical
reasons and especially we want to
separate from the Secret Service I guess
of course have you ever been offered or
asked for your services by criminal
hackers I was just one time it was just
a question and I took it as a joke
because I'm publicly known as a
spokesperson for the CCC and it would be
quite to ask me but
we have that cases forest people have
drifted off into the criminal element
right if you have special skills special
knowledge than you maybe will be asked
or you don't even notice it really you
just come in situations where you notice
okay this here's something wrong and
there's a gray area let's not it's
between black and white somewhere and
you don't want to go to the black area
we have that that's part of the everyday
experience from many acres okay
something different as we have seen
Constanza was born in East Berlin at a
time when that part of the city was
still the capital of communist East
Germany and she's been quoted as saying
that the fall of the Berlin Wall and the
collapse of the communist state was the
biggest present in the whole of her life
best thing that happened to her the
question is she's nodding as I say that
the question is how typical is she for
her generation on elites was just 13 in
1989 but he still took part in the
protests that led to the fall of the
Berlin Wall this photograph shows him at
a demonstration in autumn 89 in his
hometown of gusto de spy was an exciting
time as a kid you didn't know exactly
what was going on but you knew a lot of
people who attend at the first protests
were nervous now 38 he grew up in a
religious family his father was active
in the peace movement and frequently got
into trouble with the state leads would
have undoubtedly found life increasingly
hard if the Iron Curtain had not come
down
see I would have led a very different
life it would have been hard for me to
complete school and even if I had I
probably wouldn't have been allowed to
study what I wanted for leads the fall
of the wall on the 9th of November 1989
was a liberation
around 2.4 million East Germans were
under 18 at the time today that
generation sees itself as very fortunate
Slava dusty Dusty okay I think we all
grew up with an implicit understanding
on the part of our parents our teachers
and indeed society that we were or would
become West Germans sent Audrey on
electronic grew up in the East German
city of rostock 11 years old in 1989 she
watched the fall of the wall on TV in
2010 she founded an initiative called
third generation East Germany which now
numbers around 2,000 members it seal is
indefinite your goal is to provide a
platform for people to address their
past octa technique bad sequence occur
that past includes formative and often
challenging times many had parents who
struggled to regain their footing and
post reunification Germany but while
they might have lost their jobs the
younger generation enjoys undreamed of
opportunities businesses does we know
that a political system can be replaced
so we have wider horizons a new Blee
cuttin and I think that we have a
greater willingness to consider
alternatives and seek solutions oh no a
new zoo I cillessen and Rihanna and
others her age were the lucky ones and
will go down in history as reunified
germany's first generation I suppose
Constanza the first question is where
were you when the the wall came down
actually almost asleep but my parents
woke me up to take a look at into the
television of course because everybody
was watching the news you were asleep i
was i was in the bath I'd been for a run
in and and the people I were living with
came home and said what you doing in the
bath the wall is coming down still once
you have a look at the wall coming down
um you said it was the biggest present
in your life the biggest the best thing
that's happened for you yeah present a
gift yeah uh y-you because traveling
around the word was really the freedom
to do that you're really important to me
it was like opening up the world
as an East German person you couldn't
even imagine to go to New York it was
really like traveling to the moon and as
a walk him down it was a of
opportunities you couldn't even imagine
before it was a problem too and because
I have to decide well what are you
supposed to go to the life and it was
was much much more a determinate have to
reinvent yourself a little bit yeah yeah
there was one woman in the piece who
said that she felt her so she was under
because Big West Germany sort of took
over East Germany in a lot of ways I
think that's all yeah but I liked it if
I went to West Berlin first time I was
impressed because it was almost colored
or market marketing stuff and of course
and it smelled good it was quite
different and as Western pop culture we
left that at least for me as a teenager
it was a good thing big deal yeah and
when you meet people of your own
generation because this piece was about
that your generation yeah you were I
don't know how old were you when the
wall came down 15 16 yeah when you meet
people who have your your age from the
former East Germany do you sort of think
yeah we're the same sort of people are
where the differences in East German
society so great that wasn't sort of
what topic sometimes yeah and if you
hear specific charms then you'll notice
okay this is someone from from East
Germany and then uh it's mostly that
they start talking about it what did you
do after the ball came down because well
we share a history and a specific
education yea which was different we
read different books in school than
Western pupils did and where you have a
connection what's important yes why you
is where you grew up is where you play
you pay you spent your formative years
yeah of course I know like Russian
literature and Stefan most Western
pupils didn't even know i can understand
yeah we saw we saw in the earlier in the
in the report right at the beginning
were about the about the CCC we saw
really quite young people in e in East
Germany with computers and you said
yourself at the age of 11 you had your
first sort of
experience with computers what what
happened to all that when when did these
German authorities begin to think we
don't necessarily want to have these
people with their own computers
collating their own data I guess they're
in the eastern part there we're not much
problems not many problems but the war
came down too early for the eastern
government to see the problem but there
are maybe hackers because the computer
development wasn't that far and where
the connected computer would actually
and that doesn't walk him down the the
two hacker communities at least in
Berlin they merged actually hmm I am as
a reporter I am very often asked around
the NSA and the Edward Snowden story you
know people people will say to me
Germany went through two dictatorships
there was the there was the Nazi
dictatorship there was these German a
society very authoritarian very heavy on
control and that makes people in Germany
particularly sensitive to you know these
kind of things and and that's something
that I quite often say when I'm
reporting from Germany I say that that
is a truth about Germany is it true I
guess it's definitely true totally true
because and almost every family you have
a member who has his own personal
experiences with Stassi and the GDR was
actually a survey instead yeah but but
but I mean you could what I often think
at the same time though is I look at
Angela Merkel who grew up in East
Germany yeah and her telephone was
bugged yeah and she knew that that
happened she was clearly sort of a
little bit annoyed about that and don't
told President Obama so but then quite
quickly after that she said let's get
back to business as usual here because
it's not about surveillance for her it's
a question of power question of
technology and communications and who
knows who talked about what with whom
it's a question of power right now the
whole NSA scandal it's not about the
privacy of people it's more of like good
economic question and economic espionage
and power because with knowledge comes
with power and I guess
he is a politician who know that so she
didn't even address her own history in
the GDR she should have but that's very
dissatisfying it's missing isn't it yeah
sure she should stand well in front of
her population and really defend our
data sovereignty against whatever secret
services tap the faults here and collect
all that data on a massive scale but she
did not because she depends on the US
and UK Secret Service so my sister's
there's a problem but I guess we will
change that it's a matter of time oh
okay we wait and see yeah as I said
earlier in the show Constanza isn't just
an influential computer scientist she's
also an authority on the world of work
and specifically what they call the
fourth Industrial Revolution before we
hear more from Constanza on what she has
to tell us there let's just get a sense
of the latest developments when it comes
to automation in the workplace it's
still in the early stages however slowly
but surely machines are taking over our
lives self driving trucks will be on the
highways in the foreseeable future the
remaining obstacles are now legal rather
than technical elsewhere developments
are more advanced like in the cowshed
the cows have become used to Juneau the
feeding robot which has a built-in
ultrasound sensor it follows a routine
and dispenses feed at pre-programmed
intervals once I you know is yet it I
love her Juno robot it does its rounds
12 times a day and the animals London
orange yeah he clearly me
even milking is now done by a robot the
machine collects up to 60 litres per cow
per day this robotic dairy farm in
Saxony has been in operation for about a
year the gnosh of its agricultural
cooperative invested a total of five
million euros with about 500 cows it's
paying off a robot even cleans up the
manure that's one job no one's
complaining about being done by a
machine and as the boss explains fewer
workers is good for the animals the
quota is the advantage is that people
are pretty much eliminated and the
animals are left by themselves to live
at their own pace they can feed be
milked or just lie down whenever they
feel like it a robot ensures there's
fresh sand to lie on and the cows get a
welcome shower robotics is also changing
the face of journalism this text was
generated by a robot the software was
designed by a US company automated
insights a pioneer in the field of
automated journalism there's always so
much we look to machines for for advice
and I'm not sure a lot of consumers are
fully aware of where the machines are
are interfacing whether or not but if
there's big data to be analyzed machines
can simply do it more consistently and
when it comes down to trust what you
want is error-free announced automated
insights uses a unique algorithm that
searches for trends and key insights
within a given data set and creates
personalized articles it can generate up
to 2,000 articles per second it's
efficient and economical Robo journalism
is going to go places because media
enterprises of all kinds are pressed to
tighten their budgets everyone every way
they can you'll see that to the extent
they can use data to automatically
produce stories they will that's no
replacement for the human writer writing
about human stories
nevertheless forbes magazine already has
its financial reports generated by an
algorithm while the LA Times uses it for
earthquake reports it's unlikely that
automated journalism will ever make
human reporters redundant but it might
well have an effect on the job market
we'll talk about journalism in just a
second because obviously it's a concern
concern for me but you you've written a
book called our bites fry which means
sort of you don't have work anymore in a
lot of ways and that can you know that
can have many different interpretations
during the research for the book and it
was a year-long journey what did you
discover oh we discover that a lot of
fields of work are really in the near
future or quite not a day I really
connected with software or robotics or
any kind of automatization more than you
would maybe think Noah do you have a
percentage for the jobs in society how
well you know what what how big that is
well there will be a few takrut nowadays
us maybe 20 25 percent solo that's a lot
but it also means that you work together
very closely was software or or robots
but in the future it can be likely fifty
percent or sixty percent they are really
field of work which you formally
wouldn't think that can be done can be
done by a computer or by a software it's
also decision making everything which is
measurable what you're doing in your
work field and that is quite interesting
to see because it will happen very fast
it's a very dynamic development what one
aspect of that it's interesting that you
talk about what at what can be actually
measured because because these days
every sort of job that people do is
being measured ever more closely right
and seems to me that one thing that
happens that that can lead to more
efficiency for sure but it yeah well
it's maybe not the only goal but
efficiency is quite important in the
working field bedroom it's also are you
are sometimes reduced to be a sofa
clicker because the software tells you
what to do and that is your work life
the efficient
yes a problem yeah and yeah well that's
what i mean but and also they're all the
people doing a similar task if they're
being one you know working place on
maybe across the whole country can be
then readily compared with each other
and the ones who aren't sort of up to
scratch yeah we can't you see every
minute or even second if you maybe take
a look out of the window and think and
it can be measured it's of course a
problem but not awful not only that but
also if really your homework is done by
software computer or robot in the future
they're stolen we had the example of the
farm and I know you've visited you
visited farms you've seen see you you've
maybe possibly even been to that same
farm where I'm not sure what the figures
were but likes be 50 people had worked
there no not 50 people anymore every
round how'd he had yeah that's right
we're changing 22 or something like that
yeah yeah what happens to the 48 that is
the were the big questions they searched
other feats of work and it was a little
process because it where the
decades-long but nowadays the changes
are much faster you have I don't know
five years and then all were the people
who are sitting on bicycles will be
maybe automatic be a good and the well
the decades where you can change the
education and the knowledge of the
people they don't you don't have that
anymore in that fast computerization and
that's a problem which we want to point
to in that book that we have to have a
discussion right now because there are a
lot of fields of work which will be done
by machines
now at the end of the show we
traditionally have a talking Germany
quiz today is no exception Constanza
quick questions quick answers yeah are
you do you represent the establishment
or the underground the underground oh no
doubt about that for you okay do you
prefer chaos or order mmm both sometimes
your apartment at home is it chaotic or
order oh it's more chaotic you want
these nerdy so yeah yes very much so
capitalism or communism oh I like
communism much more as an idea hmm yeah
that's very unfashionable these days of
course yeah Edward Snowden is here
whistle blower or a traitor he's a wizar
blower definitely is the future for you
a fascinating or a frightening place of
course fascinating good yeah that is all
we have time for this time round with
the fascinating and very committed
Constanza courts if you've enjoyed her
company as much as I have to come back
next week until then bye-bye and just